you've lived one heck of a life
looking back there's a there's a lot of
young people that listen to this
high school college students what advice
would you give them how to live
how to have a successful career how to
have a good life
how to be a good man a woman
to be a good man or woman
if i had it to do over with i'll just
tell you what i'd have done
i would have paid attention and studied
my lesson and did the best i could
um in school in school yes and went as
far as i could have
i would have liked to been a doctor i
just didn't have the stick ability or
anybody to tell me
hey go there and do that and if you
can do that at a very young age start in
a trade
learn to do something it doesn't matter
what it is
if you learn to do something good there
is a great demand for you
and i would say that in prison that the
prison
system should come in and you get a
thief a young fan is a thief a
robber and you say all right
uh we need um we need carpenters we need
plumbers we need electricians we need
sheep
sentence them to that trade and when you
get an a plus in that
where you can go out and make you 30.50
an hour you go home
now you can you mess around 10 years if
you want to or you can do this in two
i think that would uh that's just for
the prism but anyway
i would say that they find somebody and
be true to them
that we have um uh
just be honest and and true in your life
you mean like relationships
relationships yes i mean
so many so many people particularly
our children are from relationships
where
they not wanted their divorce their
fathers left they don't know who their
daddy is
they dis in foster homes 500 000
children in foster homes in america
today
and and we have in our government
inadvertently is in encouraging those
people
my daughter is a doctor and she
delivered a couple years ago
a baby from a ten-year-old child
that child and she said in the
individual room is four generations
all of them on welfare now we got one
more and it reminds me of
elvis presley's song in the ghetto so
for an individual
learn a trade become a craftsman of
sorts yes
and uh find somebody to love and who
loves you that's right
have have a family and and and uh
and stick with it they just be surely
you're gonna get angry you're gonna get
disappointed you're gonna get all kind
of stuff but
but come back and make up before before
you go to sleep
well i i did half of those things i got
the first one i'm working on the second
one so i appreciate the advice
you